[Music]
arnell is with us to start off this hour
in west palm beach florida hey arnel
what's up
hi dave hi uh dr john how are you both
better than we deserve brother what's up
thank you for taking my call
i wanted to get some advice on
how
we can stay motivated
we
have followed the baby steps
for a couple years now we had completed
baby step two
uh baby step three and um
we basically fell off the bandwagon over
a period of time and now we're back in
baby step two
from a series of choices that we made
and
so i just wanted to you know see how we
could stay motivated um to stick with it
so that we don't end up paying off the
debt just to fall right back into it
again
[Music]
why were you getting out of debt the
first time
um
why did it sound like a good idea to you
yeah
um mainly the
financial freedom um you know knowing
that
you know our money is for us to use for
things for the future instead of paying
for things in the past why are you
getting out of debt this time
um
it's sort of the same thing but um also
just kind of practically just to free up
some extra money in our monthly budget
yeah you're not gonna make it nope
not gonna make it you're gonna fall off
again
but i can help you
it's not all bad news
[Laughter]
your issue is your why
why you're doing it isn't big enough why
you're doing it right now is ah it'd be
okay
and we might be better off and
we might get us some more stuff if we
had more money
instead of like i want to change my
family tree i want to look in the eyes
of my grandchildren someday and tell
them i was old man vanderbilt i was old
man rockefeller this start of this
dadgum thing no one's going to take over
this
branch of the family tree and take their
house ever freaking again
see the difference
your why is kind of casual
right
instead of visceral
so you guys need to there has to be a
nobility to this
i want to change my family tree i want
to be outrageously generous it has to be
other centered rather than self-centered
or you won't stick with it
the people that quit drinking that are
alcoholics never do it for themselves
they always do it for someone else
or something bigger
right
same thing you guys have to come up with
a new identity
as our friend james claire said like
you've got to say
not i'm gonna i'm gonna do this
i am we are a family
that doesn't borrow money doesn't borrow
money and the reason we don't borrow
money is we don't like being broke and
the reason we don't like being broke is
we can't be generous and we're not and i
don't want to retire and my kids have to
take care of me because we know social
insecurity is not going to do it there
you go
i want to be able to
when gas prices go to five dollars a
gallon i want to be annoyed
not crippled i want to be i want to be
like oh man i don't want to wonder oh no
how are we going to pay our bills i want
to be able to sleep i want to be able to
breathe i don't even laugh
you got to have a much bigger
understanding of why you're doing this
yeah and if you get a bigger why
you have a better chance of sticking it
out here's where i've seen this happen
it's mildly inconvenient you will keep
smoking oh yeah if it's just annoying or
you just stink a little bit my wife
doesn't like my breath that's not enough
she's not kissing anyway hey here's the
thing you all go out and paint a picture
of what this could look like and work
backwards yeah a big beautiful picture
in great detail high definition picture
not vague
you know pastels i'm talking where is
the house i want to see the beads of
sweat on the forehead when we're at the
beach where are the kids going to school
how much money are you giving away on a
wednesday night just to be super
generous like what
what does it look like how would it feel
to walk over and buy a single mom a car
for two thousand dollars and not notice
how would it feel to pay for the
adoption of a kid coming out of foster
care
so that that adoptive family could
afford to do it and that kid's life is
changing that family is changing you get
to stand back and cause that to happen
right
outrageous generosity you got to have
stuff like that in your head man because
it's just like yeah it'd be good to have
to have payments
it just won't
it statement it would be good not to
it's
do
have payments but you need a as simon
sinek says start with why salesmen know
that trick
like i probably shouldn't buy it they
know that trick
it's really hard to hit your head up
against no this is not who i am yeah
that's you can't sell over that ramsey's
don't borrow money
yeah ramsey's are always generous yeah
it's just ramsay's are
you know you fill in the blank this is
who we are and you know i told my my
daughters growing up
when they were little i said ramsay
girls are smart and pretty yeah
and when they're grown women at their
rehearsal dinner their dad looks across
and i said what's a ramsay girl
and she's still smart and pretty you can
ask her today and she's on 35 years old
you're not asking what a ramsay girl is
and neither one of them are ramsey girls
anymore that's right they're now crews
and whitmore's right all right so help
me with this dave let's turn the tables
help me with my parenting and mental
health so the other day
i walk out the door and i tell my
daughter who's
six good morning baby and i kissed her
on the head and she lost it
all you ever tell me is that i'm
brilliant and beautiful and strong i
can't take it anymore i don't want to
hear it
anymore and i was like i told sheila all
right mr phd you know what that is she's
wanting you to say it more i told sheila
i said i didn't have this class in grad
school i don't know
this what mean seven-year-olds
she said the other day she goes you
don't have to keep saying it dad yeah
sure and i said i must say it everything
every day i want you i want you to just
be so sick of me
you're going to have to be married to
that guy
you know what 20 years what will happen
is when some 16 year old
or 17 year old little predator comes
into her life
she's going to remember that she's a
precious child of god and she's special
and she's going to be looking at him
going you've got to be kidding me yes it
won't even occur to her that she's a
victim of some guy like that yeah you've
got to be kidding me she's going to run
up against the math test and think i
can't do this she's going to go nope
i'm smart and i'm pretty i'm brilliant i
can do this
somebody's going to say you know you
have a face and she could say no i'm
beautiful i know i am yeah
you apparently have eye trouble
because my dad said that i was smart and
pretty and his mustache is bigger than
your gross stringy 16 year old mustache
no such thing there is no such thing as
a 15 year old mustang